are there examples in biology of
predators that hunt by disguising
themselves as prey
how effective are they compared to other
types of predators thank you for the
infor
informative content
just let me say there's lots of evidence
lots of examples of prey disguising
itself as something that's toxic or
dangerous
yeah somatic prey but um there are some
very handsome deep-sea
fish oh god that have a
yes like a little uh looks like an
invertebrate
on a fishing anglerfish anglerfish
speaking
i'm hesitant to say anglerfish because i
know that anglerfish
is a term that applies to some amazonian
fish is that
oh those are archer fish maybe yeah i
think those are archer fish um that
shoot insects off of yeah i think this
thing attached to the yeah i think
you're right
the deep-sea ones are anglerfish um
and uh anyway they're very they're very
interesting creatures yeah um
also they are so handsome they are very
lovely yeah um
no actually they are basically um
it is not true but it should be true
that they had to descend so deep in the
ocean that there was no sunlight on
account of
just sheer ugliness there's a bat like
this as i remember that has a is so ugly
that he has a
flap but he pulls up over his face yeah
yes
show a picture we will we will show that
he's a very interesting
fruit bath yeah but not pretty nope not
pretty
um did we answer that question oh yes
yes we did
oh how effective are they compared to
other types of predators i don't so the
only example we came up with anglerfish
i don't know in order to answer the
question how effective are they compared
to other types of predators you really
want to compare
control for both phylogeny and ecology
and i don't know who the english fish
are related to
and i don't know if they're deep sea and
so it it's
likely that such fish have gone into a
new place
and therefore it's going to be
impossible to answer the question while
controlling for the things you would
have to control for
yeah i don't think i don't think it's an
answerable question yeah that's right
and i will say i'm coming up with other
examples now like when i think about oh
there was this thing
i i tweeted about it some years back uh
a spider mimic at the tail on the tail
of a
snake that causes birds to birds that
eat spiders
to come and then get eaten by the snake
exactly um
and then i had a couple more oh there
are some others kind of like that i
think snakes snakes may do stuff with
their tails
that it's not it's not exactly uh
well they're disguising parts of
themselves as prey yeah there is stuff
like this
that definitely yeah yeah yeah um and
then there's other stuff like um
you know looking blending in with a
flower which is kind of at the edge of
your question
right if you if you're a like a a mantid
disguised as a flower part and some
pollinator is going to come to pollinate
the flower it's not exactly what you're
talking about but it's really close
i mean camouflage is that's why i say
it's at the edge because
they're camouflaging themselves as
something that
indicates food yeah so i think it counts
thematically but it's not a perfect
[Music]
match